ich schreib doch einfach meinen ja mach
dich locker oder erzähl mir was dann
schreiten
dass ich vorne gesagt habe ich traue
markt nicht schon lange nicht meine das
ehrlich
ich liebe leute
einfach nur eins sie zu trinken geht
damit meint genauso mag hat sich sehr
verändert
kaum wiederzuerkennen ich glaube das hat
auch george einen ziemlich beeindruckend
manchmal frage ich mich mag das alles
nur wegen meines vaters gemacht hat
immerhin hätte er den job nicht bekommen
egal
seit kurzem frage ich mich ob es wegen
toto ist dein vater damit zu tun nichts
mein vater ihnen gehört die agentur für
die marke arbeitet
dein vater ist sein chef der chef und
brügmann media
aber du hast doch die pure ja genau aus
dem grund weil ich immer alle auf mein
vater ansprechen
das trieb ein künstler hör zu ich möchte
eigentlich nicht dass jemand erfährt
dass marken wie verlobt sind damit geht
es gerade wieder los mach dir keinen so
richtigen uns klar wir euch ja prima von
mir das haben wir alles ein bisschen
kalt darf ich ihnen noch etwas anbieten
nein danke
wo bleibt denn ich habe auch ein termin
beim frauenarzt motto geht es gut
kontakt kannst mich hören ist okay dann
rufen sie den notarzt
wir brauchen ein frank barth nun achten
sie schon erwischt
ich mache nur eine kreative pause total
sie ich habe papa gefragt aber bald mal
zeit für ein gespräch da wird's
verstehen oder aber willst du denn ein
uneheliches kind wieso suchst du dir
nicht eigentlich neue studentenjob zeit
hast du genug
dann könntest du dir mein eigenes wg
zimmer leisten falsches thema brüderchen
du könntest doch in weißenhorn und
erkennen so wird das auch mal gemacht
du willst nur von deinen problemen
ablenken ich bin raus reza war die hallo
was